um how are you when you hear this
discussion of management
of people and talent and resources
how what what what did you do well
and wrong as a control freak i'll just
use the clinical term
and as a reformed control freak what do
you do now
i think the the the main way that i
counter being controlling
is to be authentic and when i'm
authentic my anxiety drops and if i'm
trying to hide my anxiety you're fraught
you're a fraud right
you're you know you're anxious about
something you're not sharing it and so
you're presenting
a different situation and so i think
what what i do now is i'm just and i've
been doing this for years
i just seek to be more authentic even
when
it's hard to say or maybe hard for the
person to hear
and it's a constant process for me is to
really remember that by being authentic
i'm reducing my anxiety
and therefore i'm less controlling so
it's a it's a it's a whole
ecosystem for me yeah and
it's hard to say to a founder what you
authentically feel because
you you place the bet on them and you're
in business with them and
what is the fallout going to be right
you have to think that through
like if you authentically say to
somebody i'm really disappointed
in what's happened here um
which i had to say to a founder recently
and
they said uh you are like the my hero
and i i am devastated that
i've lost you've lost faith in me and i
said well here's the two reasons why i
lost faith
so so jason what i would be carrying so
use the word disappointing
right that puts you in a parent role
yeah
yeah right right and so what i try and
do is i say hey
can i be direct with you that's my yes
that's my life much better framing
right much better framing and then they
they take responsibility for saying yes
they say yes
and then we have a conversation i
definitely say disappointing also i try
not to when i say it i know
that it sets up the kind of role that i
don't want right
it's not a good role to be in yeah and
it's i still do it by trying not to you
know
there's a great scene in um
and it is obviously a father-son theme
but
in the in the film gladiator you know
the the
you know the king says to the sun your
failures as a child is
my failure as a father right and
don't don't beat yourself up so much and
then what i said to the founder was you
know like
i i didn't i feel like i didn't make it
clear enough to you
what you that that this was going to be
an inevitability if you kept
doing the same pattern over and over
again that this was going to sink the
company
and i should have been i should have
rang the alarm louder to you i should
have said it
you know more clearly more authentically
right to use your word and this is a
very weird dynamic
where uh you know as we get old josh you
and i are becoming
it's very and it's much i don't know if
it's a weird feeling for you now to be
an elder statesman in a lot of these
situations when we were the kids and it
feels like it was yesterday we were
right we were the wonder kids you know
that these old guys were
writing checks to and now where the
czech writers and people look at us as
old and it's like
i don't feel old but okay you actually
have to become self-aware of that
that your words are being taken
differently
when you you know hit 50 40
whatever than when you were the 20 or
something or the 30 something
by the way monty's right there he's
almost there
at 50. almost right there yeah he's
about to
he said i'm 49 so i'm almost right there
i mean after this pandemic i feel like
i'm 64.
this has been hard